um so are you ready today
yeah yeah okay great so so our next
speaker
is lil schramm from stanford and she
will tell us about
a graph matching in quality random
graphs if you have small subgraph
statistics
please see it okay thank you for
for the introduction thanks to all the
organizers for the invitation
um so yeah so i'll be telling you about
graph matching in correlated random
graphs with small subgraph statistics
and this is based on some joint work
with bos barak
chenin xiao ji shen lei and yuki shang
and i apologize to all of my
co-authors for butchering their names um
okay so here is the setting so the
problem that we're studying is the graph
matching problem
and it's sort of like an approximate
version of graph isomorphism so
my input is going to be two graphs on n
vertices
and my goal is to find a permutation of
the vertices that maximizes the number
of shared edges so
uh if g0 is the first graph and g1 is
the second graph
then uh and ag0 is the adjacency matrix
of
g0 and and ag 1 is the adjacency matrix
of g1
i just want to permute the rows and
columns of the adjacency matrix so that
i'm maximizing their correlation
okay so for this g0 and g1 this
permutation gets
four shared edges so the value of this
this permutation is four
this permutation gets 5 shared edges so
the value is 5 and this is the maximum
value all right so that's that's the
goal
and please like uh stop stop me at any
point if you have questions
or if i say something on a clear okay so
our goal is going to be to design
efficient algorithms for this problem
uh it's uh it's not so difficult to
show if you if you're in the business of
showing these things that
uh getting a exact algorithm for this
problem is
np hard so we don't expect to be able to
get this in polynomial time
for worst case inputs and we further
have an
hardness of approximation result based
on
something called phigae's random
three-step hypothesis so
um it's it's also unlikely depending on
what you believe that we we get a
approximation algorithm for for this uh
problem on uh worst case inputs
okay so so what we're gonna do is today
we're studying this this problem in a
randomized model we're going to study
the approximate graph isomorphism
problem in gnp
and this problem was was first suggested
by person in
but it's in it's been studied
you know in a number of follow-up works
so so here i've only listed a couple of
them
um but this is just to say that this is
a you know like a well
accepted uh average case model for this
problem so
okay so we'll consider the following
planted model uh
sorry suddenly things aren't working so
well
hmm
i don't understand let me uh let me
start over
okay great so so we're gonna study the
following planted model
so what we're going to do is we're going
to sample correlated air destroying
random graphs and the way that we do
this is we first sample
a graph from gnp and we'll call this the
base graph
okay and then we take two copies
of g and for each copy of g for each
edge independently
we subsample it with probability gamma
so with probability one minus gamma we
delete it with probability gamma we keep
it
okay so these are two independent
subsamples
each of them has average degree p gamma
n so the marginal distribution
of g zero and g one is is you know g
n p gamma and now we'll choose a random
permutation pi and apply it to g1
okay and then these are the two graphs
that we see
and it's not so difficult to see that
the
value of this permutation
is going to be something like p gamma
squared n choose two that's just by
reversing this permutation and then
asking how many edges survive
in both of the common graphs okay then
by simple
concentration arguments you won't get
any permutations gets a better value for
the graph matching problem
and just in order to kind of fix the
setting of parameters in our in our
minds
like the interesting set of parameters
for for this talk are going to be
you should think of gamma as being like
a a small
constant like 1 over 100 and you should
think of p
as being like 1 over n to the 0.999 so
we have graphs and their average density
or their average degree is polynomial in
n
but a small polynomial in n okay
and for the purpose of comparison i want
to
bring forth the following null model so
in this model what i'm going to get is
i'm going to get two graphs
and i'm going to sample each of them
independently from g and p gamma so
that's like the marginal distribution of
each of these graphs
but i'm going to take two completely
independent samples
okay and here it's also not so hard to
see that the maximum value of the graph
matching problem is going to be
p squared gamma squared n choose 2.
right so if i just take a
an arbitrary permutation this is going
to be the
the you know probability that the edges
are present in both graphs
and again in this regime of parameters
the concentration is strong enough
that basically you'll get the same as
the expectation absolute order terms
okay so so the the question that we want
to ask is when can we recover the
maximizing permutation pi when can you
when can we know what the best graph
matching is um
the following theorem of kulina and
kibayash
establishes that you can only recover
the
the permutation pi um when
you have it p gamma squared is bigger
than log n over n and this corresponds
to the setting where if you look at the
oops if you look at the sort of
intersection graph so you think about
you know think about the case when pi is
the identity and looking at which edges
are present in both graphs
uh this is this is exactly when this
graph is connected okay there's the
connectivity threshold for that graph
it makes sense that below the
connectivity threshold there would be
more than one permutation because you'll
have isolated vertices that could be
mapped to each other
um so okay but but when you are above
this threshold then you can you can do
recovery
okay so our goal will be to do recovery
in
when this condition is met
all right so how should we efficiently
recover the permutation
so for the average case graph
isomorphism problem
there are algorithms that succeed okay
so
one such algorithm is to match local
neighborhood of vertices
but but the issue is that in this
situation where your graphs are only
correlated they're not identical such
such algorithms will fail and i'll try
to convince you why for
maybe two slides now so uh
you know what you could hope to do this
to do the same sort of thing right
you could hope to take uh vertices and
then you know match some radius k
neighborhoods
but because we're applying such high
level of noise
the correlation between these
neighborhoods won't won't really be so
high right so so the
the local neighborhoods of the vertices
really really change i mean you can
think of
having um like an identical you know
like g
uh n p gamma squared
and then adding p times
uh like you know enough edges to to get
p gamma
uh to each of the copies so then you can
you can see that the local neighborhoods
won't look so similar in the two copies
anymore so this type of algorithm
uh you know doesn't doesn't seem like
it's going to work
another algorithm that works well for
average case
graph isomorphism is you you take the
adjacency matrix
and then you compute the top eigenvector
and then you order the vertices
according to the the
entry value in the eigenvector right
okay so but that also is not going to
succeed for similar reasons
because when we do the sub sampling this
is like
adding a random matrix
whose norm has uh like is like one minus
gamma
the norm in for venous norm to the to
the current matrix right so
so in in what's going to happen is that
the top eigenvector is going to get
totally messed up
uh and it's not so difficult to convince
yourself using a small calculation
that once you add this noise the top
eigenvectors of these graphs are only
going to be
you know like like polynomial and gamma
correlated
okay so so this strategy of looking at
eigenvectors and ordering the entries
it's no longer going to just work
okay so we're not going to do that so so
what what
have people done to solve this problem
so before our algorithm all the prior
work essentially had the the following
idea
so you assume that you have some start
information
uh or what's called a seed right so you
assume that there's some set
s and uh in in g zero
such that such that you know the
permutation of s
into g1 okay
and then once you have this and you know
like if you think about uh applications
of this problem many times application
are you have two networks
like two social networks like twitter
and facebook and uh
you know some people like obviously you
know which people in twitter
map to which people on facebook but
based on their names some people have
handles that you don't know
so you can you can sort of start with
this uh this like initial seat
information and then
like bootstrap from there um so in some
settings this this makes sense
um you have some domain knowledge uh and
then
you can do stuff like uh if you have a
seed that's that's
polynomially large like size n to the
epsilon where this epsilon should depend
on your average degree
you can just do a really simple
percolation
to recover the permutation
uh so that that's due to your atta and
gross cluster from 2013 and then
sort of concurrently with our own paper
another uh
paper came out by el hanan and jamming
xu
in which they show that that you can
achieve the information theoretic limit
um but you still need a seed which is
polynomially large for most values of p
okay so so there's some uh complicated
relationship between the value of p
and uh the size of the seed for almost
every value of p you would need still
a polynomial size seed and um
and if you're if you're in our setting
where we assume that you don't have any
domain knowledge you don't start with a
seed
then all you can do for these algorithms
is you can sort of guess a seed
right so that that requires you know
choosing some subset of uh vertices here
and then
and then guessing which uh set that they
mapped to here and that should take
exponential
in in the size of the seed time so
so prior to our work all that was known
was sub-exponential time
algorithms for most values of p
okay so
our result is that for p in
a large range which i want you to not
think about too hard for now i'll
show you like a little picture later and
for gamma
bounded below by a constant there's a
quasi-polynomial time algorithm for
recovering pi
with high probability okay so so we
get down from sub-exponential time to
quasi-polynomial time so we're almost
efficient
okay so uh yeah what's up with this
weird
uh range of degrees that we handle this
this doesn't look so good
um i agree that it's a it's a little bit
embarrassing um
yeah we can we can handle gnp with
average degrees that are
you know uh kind of smallish uh but
you know you know and to the to the
little o one two and the one over 153
this constant wasn't uh optimized
necessarily
or uh average degree bigger than
two-thirds
and it's actually even uh weirder we can
also handle a couple of uh discrete
points
in the in the middle okay so uh yeah so
this is this is not uh this is not a
you know this is not a book proof
uh i guess i'll say but but like later i
hope it will become clear why this
happens and i
actually think that our techniques
should work uh all the way through this
range um anyway okay so this is like a
little mystery that we'll we'll resolve
later
and um for those of you who who are
uh interested at home we can actually
handle
noise rates that are or yeah sampling
rates that are
slightly sub-constant right so if you
want like one over uh
log log n then then we can handle that
and if you want you know
one over q i guess then uh the q will
show up
in this exponent so anyway
that's uh that's that for the main
result um here's
a little uh so so our main result is
quasi-polynomial time
but if you care also about the
hypothesis testing problem
where you try to distinguish this
planted model from the null model that i
mentioned before of just two completely
uncorrelated random graphs
this we can do in polynomial time so
for for p and gamma basically as above
we can get a polynomial time hypothesis
testing algorithm that tests between the
planted and null distributions
yes i'm just talking about the word
pseudo yeah yeah okay so so pseudo means
that
it's polynomial but it's polynomial in
the um
in the you know
yeah pseudo polynomial time so meaning
meaning that
uh you know like it's polynomial but
also in the
length of the you know uh integers that
describe the
the problem right so okay so here okay
what's really going on here is that
you know if if p has like really large
bit complexity to write down
then our algorithm takes more time uh
and it will be clear why
a little a little later i hope
thanks
all right
okay so so that's that's the that's the
result
um i am
uh yeah i guess like if there are more
questions now you should you should ask
but it doesn't seem like people have
questions so i'll move on
so okay so our approach is going to be
to count small subgraph statistics
for hypothesis testing what we're going
to do is we're going to look at the
small subgraph counts in each of the
graphs and we're going to see how
correlated these are
and for recovery we're going to do
something which which is uh matching
rare subgraphs
okay so this is just uh you know if you
if you don't want to know anything about
the proof
and all you want to remember is vaguely
what we did this this is it
and but but now i'm going to for the
rest of the time explain to you
how how the small subgraph counts work
um
and some interesting concentration
questions will come up
okay so so i'll start by telling you
about the hypothesis testing
problem because it's it's simple and it
illustrates the main ideas of our
approach
and then later i'll tell you about
recovery
okay so hypothesis testing
okay so we're given two graphs uh
they're sampled equally likely from the
planted distribution or the null
distribution and we want with high
probability to be able to tell which
distribution they came from
that's the problem we want to solve okay
if we didn't care about computational
efficiency
then there's already an algorithm that
we can
use right there's a brute force
algorithm which we can use a good test
that tells these apart
is what is the maximum value of the or
what sorry what's the best
uh matching between the two graphs right
so uh
so if there's a permutation that gets at
least p
gamma squared n squared mesh edges then
we know that we're in the planted
distribution otherwise we're in the null
distribution where the value was p
squared gamma square n square
great okay but we want to do we want to
do this efficiently
so you know there's not so many things
that you can do
uh efficiently with the graphs right but
one thing you can do is you can
count small cell graphs okay so let's
try to see what happens when we count
small subgraphs and let's start with a
with the nicest sub graph uh arguably
the the triangle
so i'm going to define this this
polynomial
uh core k3 of g0 g1
and what this is going to be is going to
be the product of the number of
triangles in g
zero times the number of triangles in g1
okay so if i'm in the null model the
triangle counts are independent
and there's going to be something like
you know like
n choose 3 times p
cubed times gamma cubed uh triangles per
ng zero and the same thing in g1
so uh the value of this polynomial is
going to be something like p
gamma n to the sixth and expectation i'm
you know like i'm going to be
very loose with a constant here because
because it won't matter
so okay so that's the value in the null
case
in the planted case the triangle counts
are a little bit correlated
right so uh because
if i have a triangle appearing here uh
and i look at the reversal of the
permutation from g zero to g one it's
more likely that the triangle will
appear there as well
so this value is going to be something
like the same you know
p gamma n to the 6 for uncorrelated
pairs of triangles
but then for the n cubed correlated
pairs of triangles i'm going to get only
p gamma squared n cubed
does this make sense right so so for the
n choose three
uh triangles that that correspond to the
identity permutation
there there's going to be probability p
cubed that they showed up in the base
graph
in here and then times the gamma squared
cubed that they survive into both copies
so okay so things are looking great uh
it looks like i've got a pretty nice
estimator right like
the expected value under the planted
distribution oops
uh sorry i
i am apparently not great at this so
okay so the
the expected value in the planted
distribution is bigger by a little bit
than a null distribution
but now what we want to do is we want to
understand if we also get concentration
okay uh and
we can see that that there's kind of a
problem here right so like
even if we're optimistic and i'm going
to return to this
this optimism uh later so so suppose
that we're
as optimistic as possible then we would
have that the
variance or the standard deviation of
this quantity should be something like
the square root of the expectation right
but then if you compare these two
numbers here you can see
that the the standard deviation is off
by a factor of uh
so so this is larger by a factor of a
gamma
cubed
okay so so the the estimator is okay for
the expectation but it has
a bad variance
all right so what are we going to do
so i mean if i could have let's say
capital t independent trials of this
experiment
then i would be able to to drop the
variance so imagine that you get instead
of getting
just one copy of g0 and g one imagine
that you get
you know t independent uh experiments
right
so then the expectation won't change in
in the planted case
uh the expectation won't change in the
in the null case either
but we'll be able to reduce our variance
by something like one over square root t
right just using kind of these standard
uh calculation arguments
and now we can see that if we can take t
to be at least one over
gamma to the sixth then uh the variance
or the standard deviation will be
smaller than expectation
and then we'll have a good good
hypothesis test
okay you have to bound the variance in
the planted case as well
all right so so i mean this is really
silly because you know the problem
specification is that you get one copy
of each graph
so so that's not going to work so
instead of
independent trials we're going to try to
find subgraph counts that are nearly
independent
okay so suppose that we have t different
subgraphs let's say that
you know you can think of h1 as being
triangles
and uh you know ht is like some other
crazy graph
if we have t independent subgraphs then
we could we could do this uh same
experiment we could
have the correlation be the average
over these two different subgraphs of
the correlation of those upgraphs
okay and now now the the question is
what properties do these different
subgraphs have to be in order to have
independent seaming subgraph counts okay
so so now we we return also
uh to the to the question of of
concentration in general
right so uh so
you know this is this is something that
that uh like i think eridish and rainy
in their first couple of
papers about erdofanian graphs already
realized but
but subgraph counts concentration in gnp
is a little bit more delicate than you
might
initially realize so
uh to illustrate this let's let's look
at the following example so suppose that
i'm in gnp
and i'm in the setting where p is like
uh n to the minus 6 8. i know that i can
reduce this fraction a little bit but in
a moment you'll be grateful that it
that this is what it's like um okay and
say that i want to know
the number of copies of this graph h
it's like a k4 with a tail of length two
okay so how many uh labeled copies of h
exists in g
so if you compute the expectation this
is just going to be something like
you take the n choose six possible
vertices that h could be on
uh oh yeah this has uh six vertices
uh and eight edges right
so so you take the you you choose
vertices that it could be on
um you take the number of distinct
labelings that you could take for those
vertices
right and then you take uh p to the
eighth that's the probability that all
the edges are present
so that's like you know order one for
for the setting of p
okay so so i expect to see constantly
many uh h and g
but now if we zoom in on this k4 that's
a part of h
how many labeled copies of this will we
see well we can do a similar sort of
computation there's going to be
n choose four vertices and and there's
six edges so
uh p to the sixth is the probability
that we'll see one
and for this setting of p this is sub
constant it's like one over root
n right so so what this means is that
and now and now you can you know you can
apply whatever markov's inequality
and see that in a typical draw of such a
graph of such a gnp you don't expect to
see any k4s at all
and so what this means is that the
count of h in g does not concentrate at
all around its expectation
right there's some low probability event
the presence of a k4 which means that
once there is a k4 there will be many
many copies of h
and that's what drives the variance
okay and and uh yeah and now you know
once
once you once you know about this um
it's it's
kind of an exercise to see that if you
have a constant size graph
the variance in the number of copies of
h in your graph
is going to be like proportional to the
expectation squared
divided by the expectation of the
minimum sorry it's divided by the
expectation of the sub graph of h
with the fewest expected number of
appearances
so uh okay
so so uh and and the same thing
it doesn't only compute or sorry it
doesn't only control
variance it also controls covariance of
different subgraph counts right because
you can imagine that the same sort of
thing will
will happen uh for this graph h and this
graph h prime
you know because they both they're
different subgraph counts they both
contain a k4
you know uh so so this means that the
the
yeah the covariance will be very
different from the um
so yeah sorry so so you know once once
there is such a k4
then there will be many many copies of h
and h prime co-occurring
uh all right hopefully this hopefully
this is clear i
i people look a little bit confused on
the uh
okay
all right so so the property that we're
going to want our subgraphs to have is
called strict balance
so again this is this is a property that
was already identified by eridition
rainey in their
early studies of subgraph counts
but but okay so we say that a graph is
strictly balanced
if all of its strict subgraphs have
smaller edge density
right so subgraphs that are strictly
balanced include cycles
trees
that are not strictly balanced include
you know our friend h from
from a couple slides back um you know
this cycle
with a with a hair dangling of it if you
remove the hair
you're going to get a denser subgraph uh
two copies of the same graph you know if
you take one of them you'll get a graph
of the exact same
density all right so
so but but but uh if you have strict
balance
then and also you have it set up so that
the expected number of appearances is
constant
then any strict subgraph has
super constant expectation right because
the because the ratio of uh
vertices to edges will be larger
and for this reason we'll have that the
variance
based on the calculation on the previous
page the variance is going to be
little one of the expectations squared
and so now by you know second moment
method we get concentration of the
subgraph counts around the expectation
and not only will we get concentration
of the counts but we'll also get near
independence so asymptotically the
counts will be independent
so so the counts will concentrate around
the means and also
for any pair of distinct graphs uh
i and j or h i h j the
expected uh product of the of the counts
is going to be like
basically the product of the expected
accounts
okay so so that's that's essentially
what we wanted so now we we have our
testing
algorithm our testing algorithm will be
we'll choose some set of strictly
balanced graphs
um with with some number of vertices and
some number of edges
chosen so that the expected number of
appearances is constant
because because this is the regime in
which the sort of concentration
arguments from the previous slide will
kick in
okay now we're going to compute the
average correlation
of the subgraph counts in in the two
graphs
okay and then we'll we'll apply some
threshold and if this value is bigger
than the threshold then we'll say that
we're in the planted case and otherwise
we'll say we're in okay so that's that's
our hypothesis test
okay and the analysis is essentially
what i described to you in the in the
previous pages
um you know the the expectation in the
planted case will be larger by uh you
know n choose v
times you know gamma squared p to the e
factor
uh and the variance in the null case
is going to be like the you know the
half like a square root of expectation
and we get to divide by 1 over root t
so as long as we take t to be
inverse polynomial and gamma to the e
we get that the variance and the null
case
is small compared to the increase in
expectation in the planted case
okay so so so now uh we're going to
require that
the so so now the question is how big
should we take v
and and uh and e right like our
algorithm is going to be to count all
subgraphs of size or you know some
number of sub graphs of size v
um so so okay so so basically uh
so our algorithm will take time
something like you know and choose v
times t right this
now i'm doing the runtime analysis
and okay and and because there's only
you know v squared choose e graphs on v
vertices and e
edges uh and we need this to be bigger
than t needing this to be 1 over
gamma to the 2e we can conclude that
v has to be 1 over poly gamma
so that's what's going to govern our
runtime
okay
so as long as gamma is a constant then
our algorithm runs in polynomial time
so so that's essentially it for the
analysis of the testing algorithm what i
didn't do is i didn't analyze the
variance in the planted case
um so but this is just you know like
once you have the strict balance
property then
things concentrate around their
expectations and things uh work out
okay so so the one thing that we didn't
do so i told you that we have this
hypothesis testing algorithm
assuming we have a sufficiently large
set of strictly balanced
graphs okay but now what we need is we
need to get a set of sufficiently
large or sufficiently many strictly
bounce graphs
right so so i added a bonus section
where i tell you about what these test
graphs are
okay so so we need to argue that the
test set exists
we want to take uh v to be one over
polynomial and gamma
and then we want to choose uh you know v
to the e strictly balanced graphs
and we need to set v and e so that the
expected number of appearances
is constant um so okay so this is all
very overwhelming
but you remember this weird uh thing
that i showed you at the beginning of
the talk where i said that we can only
handle
certain degree regimes for gnp okay so
this is the reason why so
um so the fact that i need to set
the expected number of copies to be
approximately one for concentration
reasons
uh will tell me what the ratio of
vertices to edges that i get
is so so this this this fixes oops sorry
so this fixes um
v over e the density
right and then we need to find
sufficiently so so what i want is i want
that for any density i can find
a sufficiently large number of strictly
balanced
graphs at that density and we can only
do it
at these densities so in all the other
regimes we we don't know enough strictly
balanced graphs
okay so okay so hopefully that made
sense
okay boys were you gonna ask something
or
no no i just need to think nothing to us
okay okay
okay
okay so so uh first of all let's let's
like ask ourselves where will we find
strictly balanced graphs so uh here is a
claim that's going to be very easy to
verify so the claim is that a connected
deregular graph is strictly balanced
okay and the argument is you know if if
you take any strict subgraph
the average equal will be strictly less
than d
okay so so awesome so that's really good
uh
so so now
uh what we're going to do is
if you have a ratio e over v which
corresponds
to an integer
average degree
then we can just take you know a random
deregular graph
okay so how many the regular graphs are
there's like like uh if
like the number of uh d regular graphs
uh on uh v vertices
is v to the omega of d
v okay and so
you know we're clearly satisfying this
requirement uh
if we if we just pick a random d regular
graph we're going to be fine
okay so that's good so so so anytime
when this quantity is an integer we're
good so we've filled in all of these
like discrete points along the
the spectrum okay what about
what about non-integer average degrees
right so we still need to handle like
many e over v which don't correspond to
integer degree
so uh okay so when
two times e over v is a convex
combination of two integers d
and d plus one what we do is the
following we sample
a deregular random graph on
uh v vertices and then we add a random
matching
on lambda v of the vertices
okay so so we'll get we'll get a graph
with the correct average degree
uh and now the question is will we still
have the strict balancedness property
but okay so so the original deregular
graph was strictly balanced
and now we just need to argue that when
we added these extra vertices or
these extra edges we didn't mess up the
strict balance property too much and and
things here end up being fine because of
expansion
so if you add a random matching to a
deregular graph
you're not going to mess things up too
badly as long as the matching is random
i mean if i added it all to like one
tiny set
of vertices like if all of the edges
were that i added
were in here then i would be in trouble
right because this would be like a very
dense subgraph
but but this doesn't happen because
because of expansion
okay so so when we do this we fill in
this regime of densities which
correspond to
average degree bigger than
three
okay but what if what if the degree is
is uh less than three
right so the the problem is that we
can't do this because
two regular graphs don't expand right
like random two regular graphs don't
expand that
okay so what are we going to do
here i realize that this looks like a
this looks like a heart and it's
but but i really mean to say less than
three
even though i also love non-integer
degrees
so okay so so what if we want this so
what we're going to do in this case is
we
will do something else we'll start with
a three regular
random graph on lambda v vertices
okay and then we take
each edge and we'll subdivide it into
k or a k plus one length path randomly
by choosing k appropriately we'll we'll
get this this to be the
the typical average degree okay uh
we have to choose the correct
combination of k and k plus one
um and now uh
we'll still have strict balance again
because of expansion
but um we're only able to argue that we
have the
necessary strict balance properties when
the ratio between k and k
plus 1 is not so large right so so this
this is probably it might be a
shortcoming in our analysis i'm not
i'm not totally sure there also could be
you know other constructions for
strictly balanced graphs in uh
in this regime okay but but you know as
as the
as the difference between the k and k
plus one path gets smaller and smaller
when k is large
um you know this becomes easier and
easier to argue and and this is kind of
the regime where where we can do it
may i ask i mean tuition is actually the
opposite so i missed something i would
say that if you just
subdivided 203 then you keep the slick
balance but if you have long chains and
then yeah so so imagine that by accident
on like one you know like in one chunk
of the graph
i only divide i didn't subdivide any of
the edges like imagine that the
kit like we're looking at k equals 1 and
k plus 1 is equal to 2.
okay so so so that's like what's kind of
happening like
right here so so you know in that case
like if i accidentally
don't subdivide any of the edges in
in some part of the graph then that is
really dense compared to the part where
i did subdivide the
edges so so you just want the the
difference between like the number of
yeah exactly okay thank you yeah
sorry i'll just finish the sentence you
just want the difference between
having subdivided into k and having
subdivided into k plus 1 to be
like negligible and that happens as k
goes to infinity
okay and and we're able to get it for
the k that corresponds to you know
n to the one over 153
um probably like you know maybe if we
worked harder we could uh
get that to go up farther further and
and like i actually sort of conjecture
that
this kind of construction should work in
this whole range
um but but we didn't i mean we didn't
prove that for
for this result okay yeah so so
like uh i would conjecture that our
construction would demonstrate test sets
for all
um you know like uh densities that you
would need
um also it's it's possible that you
could do things like
look at um like labeled
graphs in order to you know get like a
different version of strict on so anyway
i mean i think there's all kinds of ways
that
that one could imagine filling in this
regime with with similar ideas for what
you're um
like subgraph counting you know the
overall strategy of subgraph counting
and applying a threshold
um
okay so so one one more thing is that
you know
so here uh things were really nice
because we were working in the regime
where v the number of vertices
remember this was like 1 over you know
gamma to the whatever to the 10 or
something
um and gamma was constant so so these
are constant size have graphs
right but but uh for recovery as i'll
explain
in a moment we actually have to work
with logarithmic size subgraphs
and then like everything gets really
annoying um
like strict balance is no longer enough
you need some kind of
stronger version of strict balance which
says that every subgraph that contains
like a
0.9 fraction of the vertices has
densities strictly less than
the quantity that's more than uh like
you know like
less than 0.9 times the density of the
whole thing
uh okay and that that i mean that's
something that we have to that's
something we have to we have to handle
so not only do we need to have strict
balance but we need some like
quantitative version of strict
balance for the for the recovery um and
because all the graphs that we're
working with are really nice like
random graphs or you know like simple
perturbations of random graphs
it's not so hard to establish this um
but but okay i mean just that's just to
say that you know we
like there's a little bit more work also
that needs to get it go into it
okay so now i guess um
i'll tell you about recovery kind of
briefly
okay so the first thing that i i want to
convince you is that
distinguishing is actually not enough in
order to get recovery so just because we
can tell
that the graph isn't isn't just like two
completely uncorrelated copies of gnp
that doesn't mean that we're going to be
able to recover the permutation
uh very well so uh you know like
once you distinguish there's some some
ambiguity in the matching like how
should you conclude that two vertices be
mapped to each other
one thing that i want to point out is
that in our distinguishing algorithms
our subgraph had
constant size okay and we we set things
up because we wanted
our concentration arguments to be easy
um so that
every copy appeared a constant number of
times so
actually like only a constant number of
the vertices in the graph
are even going to be like touched at all
by anything we saw
in our distinguishing algorithm and for
recovery we need to work
much harder
okay so so here i'm going to say
something that's i mean
okay so so the this is like a little bit
of a cartoon version of what we do for
recovery but but
it definitely captures the the main
ideas so what we're going to do is
we're going to identify rare subgraphs
that appear in both graphs
the rare subgraph here represented by
these little squans
and we're going to match the vertices in
the rare sub graphs so
we're going to choose again a set
so that the expected number of
the graphs that survive subsampling in
both copies right so this is like
you know like there's like n choose v of
them and then uh in order to survive
substituting something and with copies
again like every edge has to
survive with or has to exist in the
original graph and then survive into
both graphs so that's probability gamma
squared
to the e so we want this to be much
larger
than the expected number of unrelated
pairs
right so so for an unrelated pair you
know you can choose
and choose v of them in the first graph
and then choose v
in the second graph and then you know p
gamma 2
okay so so we just want to have graphs
that are more likely to have
appeared in the bass graph and then
survived independently into the two
copies than to appear independently
in both copies okay and now
if we see such a rare subgraph in both
copies it's more likely that
it's it's because the graph the vertices
should actually be mapped to each other
than otherwise and and what we can do is
we can just
you know like match the vertices in that
in those two copies and
and uh be pretty confident that we're
done with that there
okay but but now um if you sort of
simplify
this it's like you know like a couple
seconds of algebra that i don't want to
do
you see that this is actually
corresponding to the condition
that the expected number of copies is
less than one in the original graph
okay and and uh so and
and we still want it that to be the case
that every vertex appears in such a
graph otherwise or or
like at least a polynomial fraction of
the vertices appear in such a graph
otherwise we won't be able to match more
than
than constantly many vertices so uh and
remember that there's like uh
if there's v vertices uh and e edges
then uh optimistically there's going to
be like you know v
squared choose e such graphs uh and this
is like uh
v to the e and we need
v to the e times uh
the probability of a single graph
appearing like n to the v
uh p to the e this is uh
we need this to be bigger than uh you
know omega n
if we want every vertex to to you know
appear in a copy of a rare sub graph
okay but because this is less than one
what we're really asking is that v to
the e be
bigger than n and that means that we
need to take v to be growing with n
right so so we take v to be logarithmic
maybe we could get away with log n over
log log n
okay so so uh right so if we choose
v so that that there's logarithmically
many vertices in h
then we can guarantee that um
like a constant fraction of the vertices
in the graph participate in these things
and then we can use similar percolation
type of ideas
like this will be our seed essentially
and now we can use the seeded matching
algorithms that exist before in order to
get
the full matching so we recover pi
completely
okay so uh okay so here are like claims
that are just like not really true but
you know
imagine they were true and then the
analysis would be correct and then if
you want to really know the analysis
it's like
you know a slightly more complicated
version of this but the claim would be
um you know there would be at most one
copy of each subgraph in the original
graph
g the base graph with high probability
okay
and the second claim would be that a
constant fraction of the vertices in the
graph
appear in a rare subgraph
in one in in both copies okay and once
once we can establish these things
uh we're done and okay and then we
establish robust versions of these
claims
using uh like a more complicated version
of the analysis that we did for the
hypothesis
testing and then then that gives us the
algorithm for recovery
okay all of our proofs use the second
moment method and we're in this
challenging regime where the expected
number of subgraphs is
is less than one it's like you know one
over it's it's quasi-polynomially small
so that makes things like pretty pretty
tough but um
but you know we do it
okay so uh i have some
remarks in conclusion uh that are
a little bit like they're very zoomed
out so i don't know if uh
how people feel about about taking like
a more
speculative couple of minutes um
how much time do i have i have uh seven
more minutes or
yeah including questions yeah okay some
remnants including questions okay so
okay i'll i'll just do it and uh okay
yeah i'll just do it
okay so so so let's zoom out a little
bit right so
okay so what i've shown you so far i
showed you a natural
version of graphitomorphism i showed you
an algorithm that
can recover the isomorphism
in average or in correlated random
graphs
there were some you know non-trivial
concentration
concerns that came up along the way and
we managed to to
solve them um
in in a large regime of uh the you know
information
theoretically interesting uh parameter
range
um but but i can i mean
you can also see this as as part of a uh
like it's a question that's situated in
a larger sort of a body of work
where we want to understand uh
information computation trade-offs in
estimation
right so okay so the problem that we
considered was an estimation problem
right so
we had some prior on matchings and pairs
of graphs
and our goal was to estimate the
matching
seeing only the the two graphs okay so
we wanted some function of the graphs
that would give us the matching
all right and and our our measuring of
information was the correlation between
the two graphs so this this correlation
gamma
and uh the the one
uh complexity measure that you could
take so so
running time is a natural measure of
complexity but you can also
see the measure of complexity as the
degree of this function f that we're
that we're looking at so this is like a
measure of complexity that i'm i'm
proposing uh that we use
um it's it's pretty you know like in
classical complexity theory many times
people are looking at the degree
of the polynomial to compute something
as a measure of the complexity so that's
that's
going to be our proxy for um the the
computational complexity
okay so so yeah so uh right so um
and and uh and one one reason why a
degree is also interesting for
estimation tasks is that um like if you
are looking for an estimator that's
going to be robust to noise
then many times a high degree estimator
is kind of not going to be very
effective anyway because high degree
functions aren't robust to noise so
you know here like uh if we we want our
algorithm to work just as well if if the
graphs are you know gamma correlated or
like gamma minus epsilon correlated
um so okay so degree is a natural thing
to consider here
and the question in general that we're
trying to ask is for which information
rates is polynomial time estimation
possible
okay or for which information rates can
we design low degree estimators
so if we're looking at this this
hypothesis testing question
right then uh in hypothesis testing
rather than estimating something we want
to
distinguish structure from from just
pure noise so like
just distinguish this like structured
plantar distribution from our null
distribution
and here there's some sense in which the
optimal one-sided hypothesis test of a
fixed degree
has a closed form okay so what does it
mean to have an optimal one-sided
hypothesis test
you know if you only care about
one-sided hypothesis testing you can
just always output like
you know null no matter what but but
here i mean optimal and that
it's um the solution to some
relaxation to some convex relaxation
over the space of polynomials
that tries to solve for a hypothesis
test with with bounded error
only in the null case okay so
so it turns out that that the optimal
such test
of degree d has a closed form and um
in some some work of hopkins and sawyer
building on a result of barack hopkins
kelner qatari moisture and potechian
they propose the failure of the
one-sided hypothesis test as evidence
for hardness of estimation
so so this is like a lower bound against
low-degree polynomials
is evidence of computational difficulty
for the
for the estimation task
um and
they also show that this degree the
hypothesis test even though it only has
one-sided error
bounded it can be modified to also give
estimation algorithms so
so you um you know so like when up
when the hypothesis test is bad it's bad
uh like
you cannot do estimation when it's good
then
there's always an algorithm is is kind
of the claim and this is like a very
appealing
uh sort of point of view and it's uh
it's been
successful not only in community
detection but in several other problems
as well
so it's a more general framework
and okay and this work gives a constant
degree hypothesis test
algorithm and a logarithmic degree
estimation algorithm for graph matching
within this framework like it's not so
difficult to convince yourself that when
you're counting small subgraphs in gnp
this is basically like a bounded degree
algorithm
the degree is like the size of the
subgraph
so the thing is is that you know you can
look at this work as sort of a stress
test to this
framework that uh hopkins and story
propose so
one thing that happens is that um
permutations or matchings are
more complicated than just labeling you
know like laboring
labeling each vertex to be like in one
of two communities right so
this is why we get like a logarithmic
blow up here
and we only get quasi-polynomial time
algorithms rather than polynomial time
algorithms
um another thing is that actually like
our hypothesis test is not this uh
supposedly optimal one-sided hypothesis
test because
of the non-concentration of small
subgraph counts
right so because of this issue of strict
balance we actually have to modify this
hypothesis test a lot
in order to get an algorithm that that
works
um so okay and then
uh yeah great so this is just to say
that because the variance of the
structured prior is difficult to control
um two-sided hypothesis testing is
different than one-sided hypothesis
testing
um okay so so yeah so that's just that's
just all i wanted to say like
you can also contextualize this work in
the study of
whether whether low degree
estimators are a good proxy for
computational complexity of estimation
in general
and the answer is based on this paper
it might still be the case that it's a
good uh framework for understanding but
things aren't as simple as they would
otherwise appear
um as opposed in this general framework
all right well i can i can sort of see
that you know people look a little bit
lost maybe that didn't make sense that's
okay
uh going back to some more concrete
questions to to conclude um so i think
pretty clearly the the big uh open
question is can we do
recovery of the permutation in
polynomial time
um so you know like many variations on
our theme are possible
uh or you could try something completely
different like
using convex relaxation so context
relaxation
are known to work when the noise rate is
very small so when you have like one
minus little one correlation
is it the case that convex relaxations
could succeed for
a gamma like 1 over 100
another possibility is that you really
require quasi-polynomial time for
this approximate graph isomorphism in
random graphs
and i guess seeing lower bounds for that
would be pretty exciting so can you
prove lower bounds
for example in this low degree
estimation framework for this problem
uh okay another question is can you
achieve the information theoretic
threshold
um i think okay so in the previous uh
simon's workshop jamming xu gave a talk
and he
uh alluded to the fact that they have a
result for this uh hypothesis testing
question in all of the
parameter regime but i think it's not
public yet so
i'm looking forward to to hearing more
about that
okay and then and then the last thing is
can you take our subgraph counting
approach and come up with practical
heuristics that are based on
on this approach this will work not only
in average case instances but
in other graphs as well i think that's a
really nice direction
for future research okay thanks you very
much
any questions
uh hi i have a question actually even
took two questions um the first question
is about this
um recovery polynomial time i mean um
so you had um the order of works in n to
the log n
now uh suppose you want to improve it to
n to the power epsilon log n
just one thing uh i notice you construct
c which is really large omega
n
why would you just take a smaller scene
and apply that result and save some
time right that that may very well be
possible um
i guess that there's this other okay i
mean there are a lot of uh there are a
lot of uh
you know moving parts one thing is that
you need
to have uh sufficiently many
subgraphs as well in order to make the
concentration argument
go through right so so it's it's so even
now it's not like we get like
n to the order log n but you know here i
think like there's like a
pretty large factor sitting sitting out
front
um and maybe we could drop it down to uh
you know like a thousand divided by you
know
something if we only went for epsilon um
yeah but i think that like log n over
log log n is also maybe possible
uh so i think if you push our current
strategy to its limits i think maybe you
could get log n over log log n
yeah okay and and
my second question is is is more uh uh
how would you call it zooming out
question so
so um if i think about it for the point
of view of old-fashioned i mean
signal versus noise so so the noise is
gnp right just normal
but i'm not the planted thing
i'm not sure i would get for the signal
another gmp maybe maybe so and also i
think that from your proof you don't
for the planted case could you get away
with something which is not just gmp so
the best thing would be arbitrary thing
of just with some density
or maybe density and expansion so that's
just more general question
you're asking if there's a different
model that makes sense
for the structured case especially for
the planted piece
that will not be just random something
more general that's it
well okay so i mean our method is really
you know
we're really using that we know
something about the subgraph counts
and i guess that um yeah like so so for
you know i think for our style of
methods to work then
you'd need a planted model where the
where the disapproach could could make
sense but you know it's i mean
uh like in general there's no reason why
you should only consider
the correlated random graphs model for
the for the planted case and
um i think you know subgraph counts may
not be so robust to change into models
but things like convex relaxations might
be
pretty robust to changes in uh model
um so i think yeah like i think that's a
great you know
direction for future research like
getting algorithms
that are based on things like convex
programs that would be robust to
change in the planted model uh right now
we can only handle that for really
uh i i quoted this result here like you
really need the
noise rate to be quite small to make
that work even in this
correlated random graphs case
thank you any more questions
um yeah so i was wondering so on the
requirement that the average degree
has to be a union of those two intervals
like
do you see that in any other kind of
problems um
oh no i i think that even in this
problem that's like a very i don't think
it's uh
i don't think it's inherent i think it's
artificial it's uh
you know like in fact you know i i'm i'm
yeah yeah so i think i think that you
wouldn't you wouldn't
uh like that shouldn't be there that's a
uh limitation of our uh proofs
um yeah so
and i can't think of any other case
where that
shows up but maybe someone in the
audience
you know where it's not an accident of
the of the proof that it shows up um
oh and um like as for why you have this
intuition that it
it like shouldn't be disjoint uh
uh i sort of think that that you know
these like
large families of strictly balanced
graphs probably ought to exist
um at every like there's nothing really
special about
you know like i sort of have the
conjecture also that if you
maybe if you sample a random graph from
yeah i mean okay i don't know i mean but
i think if you sample a random graph
from the correct model that wasn't like
you know start with a d regular random
graph and then subdivide all of the
paths and stuff maybe it would be easy
to see
that uh that you like strict balance is
a is a property that random graphs
should
have kind of and if you you know sample
from the correct distribution i think
you would have it like in every kind of
degree regime
okay thanks
any further questions
okay so let me send this picture again
and uh the lectures assume
the 2pm pacific time bye